Did you know that you can legally fly
without having a current FAA medical
examination? I know it might seem crazy,
but if you use basic med instead, it is
possible. And that could be a huge
relief for those of you guys who don't
want to go to an aviation medical
examiner to get checked out because we
all know what they do in those
examinations. But before you can use
basic med, there are some things you
should know and some restrictions that
you really need to know about. So, in
this video, I'm going to talk about all
that.
>> [groaning]
>> Welcome to Free Pilot Training. I'm
Josh. You're probably watching today's
video because you're interested in
flying without an FAA medical
examination. And if you use basic med,
you don't have to have one. But in this
video, we're going to talk about what
you need to do if you decide to go that
route. You'll find most of the stuff
we're discussing today in FAR 6123.
But in a nutshell, if you have a valid
driver's license and you have previously
had a valid FAA medical certificate, you
may be eligible for basic med. If you or
loved one does not have stage 4
diabetes, you have a driver's license,
and you have a valid medical
certificate, you may be eligible for
basic med. Diabetes.
>> You're welcome for that. But Wilfr
Brimley brings up a really good point
here. Before you can fly under basic
med, you have to have had a valid
medical certificate at some point before
you can exercise these privileges. This
could have been a first, second, or
third class medical certificate. It
doesn't matter which one you had as long
as you had one and it was valid at some
point after July 14th, 2006. In addition
to that, that previous certificate can
be expired, but it cannot have been
suspended or revoked. Even if the
certificate was issued under a special
issuance, that's fine. You can still use
basic med. Now, if you're a new student
pilot, you're probably realizing that
you might not be eligible for basic med
quite yet because you've never had a
medical certificate in the past, but you
still need to watch this video because
these basic med questions are super
popular on the FAA written exam right
now for some reason. Plus, you might
also want to use this once your
certificate does expire. And for you
sport pilots, you're going to be able to
use basic med to allow you to fly at
night and a few other options. So,
you're going to want to pay attention to
this, too. Anyway, if you do decide to
use basic med, there are some
restrictions on what you can fly. You'll
find these restrictions in FAR 6113.
First of all, you can only fly an
aircraft that has a maximum takeoff
weight of 12,500 lb or less. This means
that if the airplane is certified to fly
at 12,5001 lb, you cannot fly this thing
under basic med. It doesn't matter if
the actual takeoff weight is 12,499
lb. You have to look at the total weight
that it's capable of carrying. Anyway,
if the max takeoff weight is 12,51 lbs
and you want to fly it, you need to get
an actual FAA medical certificate. And
actually, you're going to need a type
rating to fly this anyway. So, I think
this is a good rule. Next, under basic
med, you can only have up to seven
occupants in the airplane. And this
includes the pilot. It's not seven
passengers and then the pilot. It's a
total of seven people in the entire
aircraft. In addition to that, you
cannot fly an aircraft that's certified
with more than seven seats. If it has
eight seats, you can't just take one of
them out. It has to be certified with
seven seats or less. See, I knew what
you was thinking. You thought you were
going to be able to get one of them
carry vans and pull all but seven seats
out of that airplane.
Anyway, enough of that. Let's take a
look at a few more limitations you'll
need to follow if you operate under
basic med. In addition to this other
stuff, you cannot operate above 18,000
ft MSL if you're using basic med instead
of a medical. For those of you who
forgot, this is basically class A
airspace. Well, I guess technically
class A starts at exactly 18,000 ft. So,
I guess technically you could fly in
class A if you're super good at holding
your altitude for 1 foot. Please don't
though. Anyway, just remember that you
can't fly above 18,000 ft. Oh, yeah. And
as long as you're IFR rated, you can
operate under IFR or VFR with basic med.
Either one is fine. Next, you cannot fly
faster than 250 knots. Now, it doesn't
say anywhere in the regs that you can't
fly an aircraft that's capable of flying
faster than that, but you, as the pilot,
cannot exceed 250 knots if you're flying
under basic med. That's probably a
pretty good rule. Now, another
limitation of basic med is that you
cannot fly outside the US if you're
operating under these privileges. Now, I
actually do think that there are a
couple countries that do allow you to
fly under basic med, but I have no clue
which ones those are. You'll have to do
the research on that yourself to find
the answer to that. And if someone
knows, I would really appreciate you
putting that in the comments. Okay, now
here's the crazy part about all these
restrictions. We know that we can't do
any of this stuff right here, but oddly
enough, there is nothing in the regs
that says you can't fly a multi-engine
aircraft as long as the airplane and you
meets all these requirements. So, you
can fly a multi-engine aircraft as long
as you're certificated to do so. Don't
tell them I said you could fly a
multi-engine without the rating. I know
what you're thinking. In addition to
that, there's nothing that says you
can't operate turbine engines under
basic med. Don't forget though that if
you're operating an aircraft with a
turbo jet engine, you have to have a
type rating. But as long as you have
that type rating, the type of engine
doesn't matter. In addition to that, the
horsepower of an engine doesn't matter
either. Now, obviously, you've got to
have that high performance endorsement
in your log book if you're going to
operate an aircraft with an engine that
has more than 200 horsepower, but as
long as you have that endorsement, you
can operate a high performance aircraft
under basic med. You can even operate a
complex aircraft if you want, which
means that you can fly an aircraft with
retractable landing gear. Just don't
forget to extend that gear before you
land.
Okay, so there are a couple other
requirements that you should know about
if you're operating under basic med, but
you kind of have to read between the
lines of FAR 6123 and FAR 6113.
If you have your commercial pilot
certificate and you want to operate
under those privileges, you have to have
at least a secondass medical
certificate. I explained this in a
little more detail in my last video, but
what that means to you is that if you
don't have at least a secondass medical,
you cannot carry people or stuff for
hire. So, if you're operating under
basic med, you cannot get paid to carry
people and stuff around. Basically, when
you're operating under basic med, you're
limited to private pilot privileges.
That's why FAR 6113 applies to us in
this case, even if we have a commercial
pilot certificate. Well, what does that
mean to me? Well, that means we can fly
in the furtherance of a business. This
would be like a aircraft salesman or
something like that. We can share flight
expenses with our passengers as well.
And we can conduct search operations
like the Civil Air Patrol does. Now,
here's the crazy part. If you dig more
into 6123, you'll see that a flight
instructor can also give instruction
under basic med. The caveat to this is
that he still needs to meet all those
restrictions we talked about earlier.
So, your instructor can't give you a
checkout in an aircraft with eight
seats. If he's operating under basic
med, he's limited to seven seats, 12,500
lb, 18,000 ft, and 250 knots. Okay, so
let's look at a few more requirements
for flying under basic med. First, you
have to have a current and valid US
driver's license. The funny thing about
basic med is that the federal aviation
regulations don't actually call it basic
med. They call it operations requiring a
US driver's license. So, basically,
you're using your driver's license as a
medical certificate when you're flying
under basic med. I guess they figure
that if you're healthy enough to operate
a car or a truck at high speed, then
you're probably healthy enough to
operate an aircraft as well. But anyway,
what that means to you is that you have
to have a current and valid US driver's
license. Any state license is good as
long as it's valid and not expired. You
can't use a license from another
country, a passport, or an international
driver's license. These won't work. The
FAA is trusting your state driver's
license medical standards. So apparently
we don't trust a driver's license from
other countries. Think about that the
next time you're driving overseas. In
addition to having a current and valid
US driver's license, if you want to
operate under basic med, then you have
to agree to a national driver register
check. And basically, this is a database
where they can track all your speeding
tickets, DUIs, and all the driving sins
you may have. So if you have something
to hide from the FAA, you may just want
to get the standard FAA physical. Now,
I'm not saying you should hide things
from the FAA. I'm just saying. I don't
know what I'm saying. Just keep that in
mind. If we go back to FAR 6113, we'll
find a couple other requirements for
operating under basic med. First, there
are two things that you have to carry in
your log book anytime you go fly when
you operate under basic med. First, you
have to have a completed medical
examination checklist. Now, it doesn't
really say this right here, but this
checklist has to be filled out by a
state licensed doctor or physician, and
they have to give you a medical
examination and check all the things
listed on this checklist. Once they
check you for all the stuff listed here,
they'll sign this form, and you'll keep
it in your log book showing that you're
medically qualified to fly. And that's
important to remember as well. Make sure
they sign this thing. It's not valid
unless they sign it. This examination is
what the FAA calls a comprehensive
medical examination or CME. And you have
to get a new CME every 48 months. And
those are not calendar months. That's
just a 48-month period. So if you got
the exam done on June 11th, then you
have to get another one done by June
11th, 48 months later. But as you can
see, this is a pretty good option
because you only have to get checked by
a doctor every four years under basic
med. Now, you can get this checklist a
couple different places. You can find it
in the FAA's advisory circular 68-1. And
if you Google search AC68-1,
it should be one of the first things to
pop up. Just make sure you have the most
current version of this advisory
circular. At the time of this video,
we're still on version A for this
advisory circular. So, just make sure
you have the most current version. You
can also just go to www.fa.gov
and search for comprehensive medical
examination, and it should be one of the
first things to pop up. I'll just click
on this one right here. and open it up
and then I'll just print this guy out
and take it with me to the doctor when I
go get the exam. In addition to the
comprehensive medical examination, you
have to have one other thing in your log
book. You also have to take a basic med
education course every 24 calendar
months. And as I've mentioned before, a
calendar month just means that your
training expires on the last day of the
month, 24 months from the date you took
the training. So, if I took the training
on the 4th of July because I don't have
a live, it expires on July 31st, 24
months from that date. Now, it's really
important to note that this video you're
watching doesn't count for this
training, unfortunately. But there are a
few places where you can get this
training, and it's usually free. They go
into a little bit more detail on the
things that you have to know before you
can operate under basic med. If you
search for basic med on the FAA's
website, it's usually one of the first
things to pop up. I'll just click this
one right here. And it looks like you
can actually get that CME checklist here
as well. But down here, it looks like
I've got two options for that basic med
training. I don't know much about this
one right here, but I've never been
disappointed with an AOPA course. So, I
recommend just doing this one. And once
you've completed the course, you'll get
a certificate of completion and you can
print that puppy out and put it in your
log book. And now you're ready to fly
under basic med. Now, they'll go over
this a little bit more in the training,
but if you happen to have any of these
medical conditions right here, you'll
have to get a one-time special issuance,
and that just basically means that
you're going to have a hard time getting
medically qualified. And quite frankly,
there's a good reason for that. If
you're having heart issues or there's a
chance you could have a seizure or
something in flight, it's probably not a
good idea to let you fly without making
sure that you're not a risk to others.
In addition to that, there are a few
mental health issues that will require
you to get a one-time special issuance
as well. That way, we can be sure that
you're not putting others at risk. And
once again, they'll explain all this
stuff in a lot more detail in the course
you need to take. But just know that
these conditions might keep you out of
the sky or at the very least, they'll
delay you from being able to fly. If
that's the case, you might consider
going after a sport pilot certificate.
Under the new Mosaic rule, sport pods
actually have a lot of privileges and
can fly without a medical. And I'm
actually building a playlist
specifically for sport pilots. So, if
that sounds cool, be sure to subscribe
to this channel. Now, there's one more
thing I want to mention that should go
without saying, but I'm going to say it
anyway. When you're operating under
basic med, and really when you're flying
under an actual medical certificate,
too, there are going to be times when
your health might affect your ability to
fly. And I'm just going to say this
once, don't be stupid. Please don't fly
and or get treated by a doctor. If you
have a valid medical or if you're flying
under basic med legally and you start to
develop health issues and you still go
fly, you can get yourself in a lot of
trouble if you have an accident and they
find out that you weren't actually
healthy enough to fly an aircraft. And
if you're wondering what regulation they
could use to get you in trouble, look no
further than the trusty old 9113.
No person may operate an aircraft in a
careless or reckless manner so as to
endanger the life or property of
another. And if you're not healthy
enough to be out flying, you are
endangering the life or property of
another. And I know I might sound like a
robot when I say this, but consider the
I'm safe checklist. If I'm dealing with
any of these issues right here, any one
of these is a good reason to just ground
yourself. It's not worth flying if
you're going to be putting yourself or
others at risk. Now, before I leave you
today, I just want to remind you that if
you do decide to operate under basic
med, don't forget to put that signed CME
checklist and your training certificate
in your log book. You have to have those
with you if you're going to be operating
under basic med. Hey, I hope you enjoyed
today's video on how to fly without a
medical certificate. If you enjoyed this
video, be sure to hit that like button.
In the next video, I'm going to be
talking about your privileges [music]
and limitations as a pilot. So, if that
sounds cool, stick around. See you.